hello everyone and welcome to the third
and final game of the usgs championship
2021 tie breaks it's fabiano caruana
versus wesley so uh no it's not i just
forgot to update my interface give me
one second uh there we go uh you know
this is a perfect example of how i'm you
know just saying what i'm seeing that's
pretty crazy uh but no obviously that
was game one this is game three wesley
saw versus samuel savion and it's uh
well it's everything for the win in the
first game wesley defeated fabi with the
black pieces then in the second game
fabi defeated uh savion with the white
pieces obviously
and it was uh pretty
pretty crazy and now the situation is
that uh now wesley is up a point fabi's
up a point and seven still zero points
so wesley uh basically only needs a draw
uh to win the the entire thing uh but of
course uh
seven will try everything to to make
that uh not happen and then everyone
will have a point and then we'll we'll
see what happens so it's a really a
really wonderful game yeah let's check
it out there's quite a lot to enjoy also
one quick announcement on thursday at um
8 30 central european time we're going
to have a very nice tournament unleashes
you guys are all invited i will post a
link to the tournament in tomorrow's
video and i will have a guest for the
first stream uh julian hosp of cake defy
uh so you guys can join in on that um
you know ask some questions uh you know
enjoy some chess and you know
have some fun with us uh that being said
uh let's check out the game uh wesley
with the white pieces opens with d4 we
have g6 by savion going for the modern
defense and now you already know that
anything can happen uh we have c4 bishop
to g7 and now knight to f3 uh we have d6
knights to c3 and now knight to d7
preparing the very sneaky e5 and the
knight to e7 so here we have e4 uh e5 by
seven and now bishop to e2 by wesley we
have knight to e7 uh so really a a
sneaky way of developing your pieces but
now your knights are not in the way of
your pieces so yeah philidor would
commend you for for such ideas and now
you can execute c5 and f5 whenever you
feel like it so wesley castles uh samuel
castles and now rook to e1 by wesley we
have h6 not allowing bishop to g5 and
bishop to f1 now the bishop is tucked in
for for later use and now the rook has a
very nice control over the e file
and now we have the very early and the
very aggressive f5 so
how can westley continue here well this
is exactly what he wanted out of this
game uh because he really wants to play
active chess he's already in a very good
situation in the tournament and he has
the white pieces and now with f5 black
is saying i want to play for the win and
that of course gives wesley a lot more
chances to win as well so d captures on
e5 we have d captures on e5 and the
position has been reached before no one
moves heroes on like b3 e captures on f5
is a known move knight to d5 is a known
move but the move that wesley placed is
a new one so already as of movie 11 we
have a completely new game wesley pushes
b4 and uh uh this is one game where you
really want to follow that b4 pawn and
what it can accomplish so here
we have knight to c6 it's a question
whether you want to
play b6 or maybe c5 maybe try and uh
stop the the the pawns this way but uh
savion decides to do it differently he
plays knight to c6 he wants to bring his
knight to d4 which is uh great of course
if white captures then you will have
already a nice pass pawn on d4 but uh b5
attacking this knight knight to d4 and
now bishop to a3 going after the rook
here and now what do you play here well
it's a really tricky position uh rook to
f7 is what is played in the game and now
comes uh well something that you guys
probably are expecting and that of
course is c5 now bishop to c4 is the
threat and you can see how how wesley's
bishop pair
you know just came alive out of nowhere
and this is the beauty of tucking in
your light square bishop for later use
then you can play more like c5 and like
bring it to c4 with uh you know
great uh consequences for white another
idea in instead of c5 but this is only
if this was not a rapid game it could be
something like e captures on f5 for
example knight captures on f3 the queen
captures and now if rook captures an f5
uh queen to g3 and it's a really really
tricky position with the g6 pawn hanging
the the the rook coming to d1 it would
be a very very difficult position for
black to play that that was a mouse slip
but okay after rook to f7 we have c5
this is a rapid game of course we want
to win as quickly as possible and here
uh you have to be very careful knight to
f8 seems to be the most resilient idea
then bishop to c four can be met with
something like bishop to e6 with both
knights now nicely covering that square
however in the game after the c5 move we
had f captures an e4 it seems like a
very nice fishing suit the knight on f3
now hanging
but this is more than enough for wesley
to win the game as uh samuel missed a
very uh
very important detail here so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
wesley and with it the us chess
championship 2021 while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on realizing
that uh well
this isn't really a threat uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh it's knight captures on d4 uh
seven was probably thinking about knight
captures on e4 and then maybe an idea
like rook captures on f3 so maybe he
would give up the exchange this way but
wesley just plays knight captures on d4
we have e captures on d4 and now bishop
to c4 and now it seems like uh you're
just gonna win two pieces for the rook
the problem is if you go for d captures
on c3 then after bishop captures on f7
king captures we have queen to d5 check
and black loses there's nothing you can
do here if you go to f8 or to the e file
then root captures an e4 of course but
if you go to f8 then see a c6 check
opens up a discovery here and now you
have to go to the file now this check or
even better queen to e6 check and that's
it queen e7 this will be checkmate so
what you would have to do here is go to
f6 but this is uh not much better just
rook captures on e4 and this king now
has no square so we're going to play
bishop before bishop captures on c3 and
that's game over so instead after bishop
to c4 uh you cannot capture the knight
this is what you guys had to see in
order to play that knight captures on d4
idea we have knight to e5 but now wesley
just uh very very happily accepts the
the exchange so knight captures and if
bishop captures an f7 with check
knight captures here uh more resilient
is king captures because you don't have
to worry about them like queen b3 you
always have bishop to e6 and the knight
is just well a much more active piece
here but here knight captures an east f7
was played now knight captures on e4 and
the black does not have the uh two pawns
in the center now it's only a d-pawn uh
and well it's a very uh strong and
defended past the d-pawn it's uh
it's just not enough so here we have
bishop to e6 now comes bishop back to b2
you don't want to worry about some
discovery later on so this bishop is now
wonderfully placed here and the
situation on the clock is some six and a
half minutes wesley five minutes for for
samuel
uh we have bishop to c4 now going after
the b5 pawn uh and a4 wesley defends it
we have a6 and now uh another uh
brilliancy by wesley knight to d2 and
this is just saying uh you you go and
capture your pawn i'm gonna play knight
to f3 and then you can just resign and
something similar happened in the game
we have eight captures on b5 a captures
rook captures on a1 bishop captures and
now bishop captures on b5
samuel wins the b5 pawn but now knight
to f3 and now uh
you will see how this is incredibly
difficult for black to play black of
course tries d3 you have to start
pushing your pass pawn but now comes
bishop captures on g7
king captures and queen the a1 with
check so what do you do you have to of
course move the king wesley now on five
minutes samuel and some two minutes on
the clock we have king to g8 uh and now
comes knight to d4 and now the threat is
of course just terrible uh if you're not
of course there's the threat of
capturing the bishop but if you move the
bishop then 96 and black resigns you're
threatening checkmate you're threatening
to win the queen and of course queen f8
is impossible because the knight covers
that square as well so this would be
just resigns on the spot so instead
after knight d4 we have bishop to c4
guarding the e6 square but now comes
queen to c3 going after the bishop and
here you can just resign it's the same
if the bishop moves 96 is still wins in
the exact same way so here we have b5
but this doesn't really help
black hole that much yes it frees up
this square for the knight so the bishop
will be protected but wesley just
captured c capture some b6 alpha and now
he has this monster b pawn so knight to
d6 and now comes knight to c6 attacking
the queen and also having full support
b7b uh b8 is now coming queen to g5
trying one last trick we have b7 by
wesley and bishop to d5 now or rather if
the knight captures the pawn then queen
captures bishop with check you're up a
piece and of course completely winning
uh so here bishop to d5 was played
hoping that maybe wesley plays something
i don't know what and then uh you get
checkmated on g2 but wesley simply
brought a second queen into the game
with check and now this queen uh slicing
all the way here this queen's slicing
all the way here this is now game over
king of seven queen captures on c7 check
and it was in this position on move 33
that samuel 7 resigned in the game and
another brilliant victory for wesley so
in the us chess championship 2021
tiebreaks which means that wesley saw is
now the winner and he didn't win the
usgs championship uh only once he won it
three times uh and the that being said
this is his second time in a row so he's
the 2020 u.s chess champion and now he's
the 2021
usgs champion incredibly incredibly
impressive uh so here you resign because
after you move the king uh this just
checkmate and you know other retreats
aren't all that impressive um either
uh so yeah really really impressive
stuff by wesley and i caught a glimpse
of an interview with wesley after the
game uh he said that the way fabi was
playing in the second half of the
tournament that he really thought that
fabi was going to clinch this and that
you know he uh was doing so incredibly
well in his final game against samuel uh
sam shankland
and he thought okay it was over i i
played a nice tournament but fabi
definitely deserved the win and he
didn't even think about the tiebreaks he
was already very tired but then after
fabi drew with chankland and he learned
that he was in the tie breaks then he uh
well seems to have caught a second wind
and he just you know
played a brilliant brilliant game okay
he had a worse position against fabi in
game one uh but that's something that
happens to fabi quite a lot in rapid
games um
uh you know when i say quite a lot i
mean like one in ten games but you know
against very strong players it tends to
happen uh he got a winning position but
then he was just down to like 15 seconds
wesley had four minutes and you cannot
play this i mean it's possible but uh
more often than not you you will fail at
that
uh so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it and this very short coverage of the
usgs championship 20 21 big
congratulations to wesley saw on winning
it
and we'll see what happens in the next
one now he already won it three times
can he can he do a fourth win
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to danush and i
would like to thank jonathan turak
charles karen david farney and tom
darryl for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
uh coverage of everything else that's
happening in the chess world checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and you
know uh pretty much whatever we do here
on this channel uh so yeah uh thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day